the delusion is that just like we think
we have an infinite amount of time we
also think that we don't have choices
that we're stuck where we are those two
together are a dangerous recipe for
complacency it makes us think hey I have
all the time in the world and B what's
the point nothing's going to change
anyway the opposite you have limited
time and it's totally in your hands
I just learned about the mutual combat
law in Texas have you heard of this
no dude mutual combat is legal in Texas
to be legal the fight must be overseen
by a police officer the police officer
is supposed to act as a referee by
breaking up the fight when an obvious
Victor has emerged consent to fight in
Texas doesn't even need to be explicitly
stated if someone's words and actions
make it clear that they want to fight
this is considered consent under the
statute and considering that Texas law
allows people to legally carry swords in
public it's hardly surprising that
consensual fits fist fights are legal
that's a remnant of uh what we would
call honor culture
well it's on a culture honor culture is
um
is a conflict resolution culture
uh that exists in lots of places of the
world today in the Middle East for
example it's very common and and really
it exists tends to exist in places where
people don't fully
um
trust the law
um
and you know uh so the more Lawless the
place that's why you know obvious often
in slums or in places where it feels
very Lawless you'll end up with a very
strong honor culture and honor culture
says that uh it's defined by real
sensitivity to slights
so thin skin so if someone insults you
can't just let that roll off your back
you gotta respond and you respond with
direct confrontation you don't go to the
authorities you respond by finding so in
other words if you insult me you know
let's have it we have to have a duel to
you know I have to you you've to restore
my reputation uh you have you know
you've you've made a yeah you know
you've tarnished my reputation I need to
restore it and I need to preserve my
reputation to someone who uh can't be
just you know you can't just walk over
me so that's on her culture that's why
in other culture you see a lot of fights
a lot of duels
um and the wild west was very on our
culture ish um
you'll notice you'll see it though in a
bar of you know a bar a Boston bar of
high schoolers where I used to sometimes
be you know you set someone bumps into
you and you you know you're supposed to
fight them you know it's it's um so
that's on our culture and and
um and I say it's a Remnant because in
pla in the U.S today it's much less
common than it used to be it's been
replaced by dignity culture in most of
the you know which is what happens and
uh places where people do trust the law
is eventually it often um
it will uh morph slowly into dignity
culture which is much thicker skin means
it's it's you know sticks and stones may
break my bones but words or names will
never hurt me um so that's if you've
been hearing that as a kid you were
raised with dignity culture which is you
know let it roll off your back it's
ignore them it's not your problem that's
the them problem but if the thing if
something gets so bad
um you know if someone's really hassling
you it doesn't say you should be a
pushover to it but it doesn't say go
fight them ever it says go to the go to
the authorities so honor culture is thin
skin you know and you go direct
confrontation dignity cultures thick
skin but when it gets a certain level
you go to the authorities it's like
procedural but the two places that this
is still legal in America uh Washington
DC
and Texas that's funny I don't know what
it says about those two places I mean
there's also like you know I I you hear
about like some of the southern states
like outlawing lynching or slavery
uh like
in like the last decade you know so a
lot of times there's these really old
old like laws that are you know that
seem like they're from from ancient
history but actually technically the
legal code still this sort of Vestige of
a Time Gone by I learned as well that um
you know the House of Lords in the UK
where the guys are going back and forth
between each other and they're sat on
those green benches and you've got the
speaker of the house the distance
between those two benches is precisely
the length of two swords at arm's length
so if a man was to hold it out if
somebody had I didn't know scurried his
good name and he was to hold a sword out
and the other one was too that he would
they wouldn't be able to swing at each
other and they wouldn't be able to hit
each other
yeah I mean and and we we can laugh at
it
because it sounds insane but if you
lived in an honor culture time you would
be like this we all we I would too you
know like if you lived in a time like
that and someone insulted you you would
definitely want to go fight them and
that's why duels happen I mean this is
you know in early U.S I mean people
would go and shoot each other one would
often die because of an insult which is
so foreign to people living in a dignity
culture today yeah one of the
conversations that I've seen you have a
good bit recently is about the shortness
of life and given the fact that life is
pretty short how do you remind yourself
not to waste it
oh yeah I mean one thing I've been
thinking a lot about is when you you
know so you know sometimes I will it if
I just sit and you know hang out at my
apartment and work over the weekend or
just do you know maybe I'll go grab a
meal with someone and hang around maybe
it's raining and I watch TV you know the
weekend flies it's like it was Friday
and like now it's Sunday night and like
nothing happened it just felt like a
second
versus
sometimes you take a weekend trip you go
somewhere really interesting or you you
fly somewhere you know or you take a
train somewhere or
and you go and you explore a new place
or you're with a whole new people you're
at a wedding right and all this stuff is
happening
um or even just you're you're being
really adventurous in your own
you know City or whatever and you're
actually going out and trying a bunch of
different things
um You by the time Sunday Night hits and
you're back home it feels like an
eternity since Friday afternoon I mean
it's like you can't believe it's only
been two days think about how much
happened in the last few days and
genuinely it's like who cares if the
time between Friday and Sunday was the
same in both cases your experience of
the second thing felt much longer which
to me is all that matters is your
objective experience is all that your
actual reality so you actually
you lived more you actually lived more
time if it felt like forever it means
that you actually lived a lot more in
those two days so that one of the ways
to think about the shortness of life is
yes the actual time is variable is is
fairly constant right we all have you
know at most you know 80 to 100 years
you know and uh and that's it for lucky
and you know we can't really do much
beyond that but someone who lives full
of Novel experiences and they're always
trying new things and they keep it
interesting and they're they're they
they they really have you know they live
their lives richly I feel like they
actually live like three three times the
amount of subjective time that someone
you know who kind of just sticks to
their routine doesn't try anything new
um and uh you know I I think novelty is
is a way to kind of triple your lifespan
in a way so that's one of the ways I
think about
um I I try to this is not quite your
answer I mean your question which was
you know how do I remind myself but you
know I remind myself with
um I have I make visuals about this all
the time to try to remind myself and
others
um I I remember certain things sticking
my head I was like I think I was like 30
eight or something a couple years ago
and I was in the car with my grandmother
who was 94 and she said
um
I I said wow you know she's just turned
94 and I said man 94 and she was like
yep and I was like wow I was like one
day fart you know long from now
hopefully I'll be there too and she goes
it's tomorrow
and it just hit me she was just like she
was like it's tomorrow in other words
this seems to me especially since you
know when I think about my childhood it
seems like forever ago but time moves
subjectively quicker as you go and so I
get what she was saying which is that it
probably when she looks at me you know
in my late 30s she's not thinking oh
that was ages ago she's probably
thinking it feels like not very long ago
I was right there and now suddenly I'm
here so I that stuck with me and I'm
like damn it you know I'm like I you
know very quickly my I'm gonna go from
someone
who's around 40 to who's someone who's
around 60. that's going to happen much
quicker than 20 to 40 happen it's going
to happen and it's going to feel like
there's gonna be certain friends I see
this year that aren't very close friends
that I'm the next time I'm gonna see
them we're going to both be 60 and it's
gonna feel like oh when we you know it's
been a while when's it's not going to
feel like it's been ages it's gonna feel
like oh and when's the last time we saw
each other you know and realized it was
when we were 40. so
anyway I do a lot of this thinking to
try to
um to try to not you know look back
later and say oh man I just like I let
the time fly without appreciating it or
thinking about it or like trying to
maximize it and whatever I think you're
right to look at what are the tools that
I can use in order to slow down the
passage of time subjectively and like
talking about reminding yourself of the
shortness of life
really it doesn't make any there's no
point in thinking about that unless it
impacts the way that you move forward in
life in any case so going with the
tactics first or a strategy first
perspective like how you answered it is
the right way to go about it I think and
yeah absolutely novelty and intensity
seem to be the two things that kind of
slow down our subjective experience of
the time that we're going through
conversely something that is routine
means that our brain doesn't need to
forge any new memory unit I always use
this example of I went to Africa for the
first time about four years ago and the
after we got off a plane and then got on
a safari truck and then we went on this
little boat and then we finally got
there and this guy met us at the front
Morris I don't think it was his actual
name but Morris who was one of the guys
in the windy impenetrable Forest Huts
that we were staying in I remember the
shoes he was wearing I remember the book
on Ornithology from birds that he had in
his hand I remember the sound when he
walked down the muddy track that we were
going along dude I've had the same
credit card for four years and I can't
remember the 16 digit number across the
front of it but I recall this endless
Litany of totally arbitrary things
because it was just full on novelty and
intensity I can hear gorillas in the
jungle behind him there's the sound of
birds there's different smells I've been
traveling for 24 hours
like that was maximizing the time and
yeah I think it seems like we have a
similar view of a life well lived which
is one in retrospect you're glad that
you lived you look back and it seems to
be quite Rich yeah yeah I mean it's it's
at least for me I mean that's one of the
you know objective measures that one of
the measures that seems to me
um like uh like a a very valid metric
for uh that that you want to go up on
which is just experiences
um and you know I don't know some people
could argue why you know what's why why
is that better than having a Content
being content in your routine and just
being with that and and I don't think
there's necessarily a good reason but I
think the fact that it slows down time
alone is a good reason and then I happen
to be a curious person who loves new
experiences not that I do it all the
time you know that's why sometimes I'm
kicking myself or why you know when I go
do something interesting I think why
don't I do this every you know weekend
and and to be clear you know obviously
traveling somewhere with gorillas I mean
you're gonna that's gonna be a great way
to do this right
but it doesn't have to be so it it's
much easier it can be much easier than
that you can literally go to like you
know I don't know a hardware store and
get some supplies and try a new hobby
try building something you can go get a
new musical instrument and try learning
something you can go to a museum you've
never gone to in your city you can go to
a you know travel you know make a little
destination you know that's uh 45 minute
drive away to this restaurant you've
heard there's so many ways you can just
do something that's special that's
different that's like you suddenly it
lights up this child in you this like
adventurous side in you and um and it's
so easy this whole other part of us that
just wants to resist effort so you know
that we're always you know if that side
has too much power in our head it's very
short term it's in this exact moment I
just rather hang around I don't want to
go deal with the whole thing today you
know uh some other day
and I think you have to kind of um that
side isn't very wise and often makes
some very short-term decisions that
don't serve you very well so yeah I
think it's just being aware is helpful
we often mistake a comfortable activity
for an enjoyable one yeah you know the
the couch always just seems seductive
and going out to do a salsa class on a
cold Wednesday evening in November or
something is like oh God I know I said
I'd go and do salsa but no like tomorrow
what would you tomorrow look back and be
glad that you did another I did I I saw
this uh article that looked at people's
subjective perceptions of time when
using their phones and basically what
you're doing when you use your phone is
speed running live like it's a speed
running Strat for life it is [ __ ]
terrifying if if I if I lie you know I
wake up in the morning and just say it's
you know 8 15.
and the obvious thing to do the wise
thing to do
um is to get out of bed and get in the
shower don't touch the phone just like
let your mind percolate and get on with
your day you know you know start doing
you know if you're gonna if you're not
gonna get started on work that's fine
but go take a walk do something you know
Rich something good for you
um you know do some writing just do
something you know make make a good
breakfast
If instead what I often do is I'll pick
up my phone
and it is 9 30 like that like an hour
and 15 minutes passes and nothing
happens I mean I text a little bit I'm
scrolling on Twitter a little maybe I
read a couple articles and it's just
like boom there goes like a there goes
like
ten percent of my day like 10 of my day
is gone on like and it's like I was
enjoying it the whole time I'm sitting
there all the time with the part of me
in my head saying get up this isn't good
you know that's what I call it the dark
playground when you're doing some
Leisure activity you big part of your
head knows you're not supposed to be
doing you know that it's it's anxiety
real riddle time it's not fun
um so the phone is the ultimate it's the
opposite of like the novel experiences
even if you're doing something novel on
the phone somehow it just sucks the time
it's framed in such a familiar
environment isn't it but I like what you
said about Comfort I mean I think
sometimes it's almost inversely
inversely correlated with like
um
discomfort both physical sometimes like
you said you know maybe you're going to
go climbing or something but but even
more just like emotional comfort of you
know it's very emotionally comfortable
to do exactly what you're used to doing
with the exact people used to doing it
with
um it's easy you don't have no
challenging yourself right there's no
stepping out of your comfort zone at all
and so so often even if even if it's fun
often the really novel experiences can
be uncomfortable not always you know
sometimes you're just going doing some
incredibly fun tourist activity and
um or you're doing something you love
that you haven't done in a long time but
um I think in inviting discomfort is
very important uh it's you know so many
of the things that I love now started
off as me venturing into what seemed
like an uncomfortable place once
um realizing I like something getting
addicted to it now it's a regular
feature of My Life
um I I you know I use the example like I
used to just write blog posts just text
now
um my blog posts were all heavily
Illustrated with you know hand-drawn
stuff and you know stick figures and
diagrams and I just love putting visuals
in that didn't just happen right like it
was binary it went from it there was no
drawings to there were drawings and the
the the the the transition point was a
day when I
did something icky I took a drawing
tablet that I saw and I plugged it in as
and I didn't know exactly how to even
whether I had the connector how do I get
it in my computer will it is it
compatible with my computer what's the
software how do I get that do it do I
need software for this once it's done
how do I get the thing onto my blog this
was earlier you know it wasn't as
obvious you can just obviously export
something and upload it so I was
thinking can I even get visuals onto
this like primitive blog this was back
in
I think like a 20 you know 2009
something like that and
so often I just there's there's a
hundred things still right now in the
queue for me that are that are like that
where I'm like I know I'd probably be
good at it or I might be good at it and
I'd like to try it but it's just icky so
I haven't gotten over them but that one
I did and because I did I realized oh
okay suddenly the all that icky kind of
like I don't know how to do this the
aching this one away I was like this is
Nikita you plug it in you download this
simple software you know you you draw it
you export you upload it's done
and from then on I just it became a
staple of what I do is I draw and so
like that's an example of something that
is very comfortable for me now started
out as me having to face discomfort
that's the step that most people I think
struggle with uh increasing when I when
I first started the show I was really
really interested in getting people from
uh really struggling to just getting off
the ground and that's still a
conversation I often think about like
how is it that you just encourage
someone to get past that very very first
piece of friction but one one of the
things that we've referenced there is
um like a regret that I didn't spend the
weekend in the most uh exuberant
Fantastical way that I could have done
and then also with this people could
look back on all of the opportunities
that they've had to lean into discomfort
to maybe develop a new skill that now
three years hence they would have been
capitalizing on or really competent in
or loving it how
do you avoid dwelling on the decisions
that we didn't make in the past
yeah I mean so as as I tend to I make
visuals that help me and sometimes
others
um
like
reframe because a lot of times
what would the the the the time of
visual is perfect for something like
this is is not you know to
make us believe something that's not
true or like help us fool ourselves it's
the opposite it's like there's a lot of
our brain is not really a a rational
truth machine it's not great at those
things it can be okay at those things it
can you know but it's it's nature is to
be very to make all these assumptions
and to kind of have this to be in this
kind of
um Groove about various lines of
thinking that it's just natural for it
to be in and they're often not mapped on
to reality well so part of the reason I
make the the life calendars and stuff is
because one of the things our brain
um thinks about
or assumes is that time is infinite you
know and again I know your rational
brain doesn't think that but uh like I
said you know if I see my friend a
certain friend who I like but you know
we're not best friends and I see maybe I
see him once a year and we get we get
dinner once a year and I think yeah this
is great this is a friend in my life I
think we when I leave that dinner I'm
like yeah we have hundreds thousands
more of these Hangouts you know I mean
this and it's like no uh you know maybe
if uh it's if the if if the one of us
only lives till 78 and we're both 40 and
we you know do this maybe even slow down
a little bit maybe we've got 30 of these
left Maybe 25. wow right and so our my
brain our brains are not thinking that
way they don't realize that this is one
of the 25
the Hangouts I have forever with this
person no you know look you can go crazy
if you're thinking about that you don't
want to be you know weird and emotional
at your dinner with your friend all the
time but like
to just a to prioritize these things and
be to enjoy it when you're there to
actually try to like you know when
you're with your family at Thanksgiving
uh your whole family is there oh my God
how many more of those do you have uh
who knows
don't be on your phone you know like go
an extra day don't rush out you know
actually try to spend some time there do
something novel with them don't just sit
around you know watching the game you
know open and game play a game try doing
something interesting you know you know
start an interesting combo dinner
whatever so that's one example now you
asked about you know a regret and how to
kind of you know not let regret about
the past consume you um and so another
visual I use which is uh I think also
helping us kind of See Clearly through
what is a natural delusion
um
is it's I it's um
I I like I think of it as like my green
tree
um uh Visual and um uh I think if if you
Google like Tim urban life paths Dean
will be able to put it up on the screen
so it'll be it'll be up on the screen at
the moment for the people that are
listening you better you can give them a
rough explanation perfect so yeah so
basically when we're looking into the
past and regretting which we all do
right we all are on a huge tilt about a
hundred things that didn't happen or
that we said that we should in this
letter that we didn't do that we should
have done
or that we didn't do not you know until
it was too late or whatever that's true
those things are real that's not it's
not that that's not true yeah I mean but
but but we all have it that's there's no
human that's gonna get to adulthood and
not have that so first of all it's not
like I did something wrong that I have
these regrets everyone
has them right it's just which ones are
you which ones do you happen to have
okay
um and you can't do anything about those
and you couldn't have you know avoided
having them so you shouldn't beat
yourself up about it and the question is
like how do you proceed into the future
to minimize regrets in the future
because you can't avoid you're going to
have some regrets in the future you know
future users are going to have some
regrets about stuff that you haven't yet
made the mistake on and that's also
inevitable but you can minimize these
right you can get better and better you
can have a better good decision to
Future regrettable decision ratio as you
get older
um and so
the left side of this
diagram is all the paths that you the
road's not taken the paths you you you
you could have with different decisions
some worse than your current life maybe
and some better right so it's you know
you also got lucky sometimes or you you
really made a good wise decision right
so it's a mix or it's a mixed bag
looking into the past
but the implicit assumption when we get
upset about those is that I could have I
had agency back then I could have done
something if I had just been a little
bit wiser or a little bit gutsier you
know I could have had it differently
right so that's this feeling of past
agency we we feel
but then when we look into the future I
think
we spend so much time looking at all
those black lines that we then kind of
think well but now this is just my life
right so I made those decisions and I
you know and here's where I ended up and
this is just what happened and now
here's my life for better or worse and
this is the life I'm living which is
kind of an assumption that you're on a
Green Path which is the life you're
living that just extends a singular
Green Path into the future that you're
stuck on like you're in a tunnel you
can't get out of it now and that's just
where you are
so that's exactly the opposite of the
thinking you're doing when you're
regretting the past because you're not
you're suddenly removing all that agency
all that oh I could have done better I
should have right which means you had
you had the ability to when you look
into the future it's as if you're like
well but now it just I'm just beholden
to fate I'm beholden to my previous
decisions and that's where I'm stuck I'm
handcuffed no you're not
you have in 20 years you will look back
and all of the black lines those are yet
to happen you oh they're all open to you
currently so you have this big vast
Green Tree stretching out into the
future
that will when you're 80 will be black
lines like the ones be you know behind
you now they'll be all close to you but
the moment they're bright green right
and you have that agency and you can
look back and instead of being upset
about the regrets you could say these
are my oh that's motivation and that's
wisdom so I'm gonna what did I learn
what are those regrets what did I wish I
did differently amazing so now I can go
and crush the Green Tree because of what
I learned in the black tree so I love
that visual because the delusion is that
just like we think we have an infinite
amount of time and somewhere in our
heads we also think that we uh we don't
have choices that that we're kind of uh
we're stuck where we are and those are
those two together are a dangerous
recipe for complacency it makes us think
well you know hey I have all the time in
the world and B what's the point
Nothing's Gonna Change anyway the
opposite you have limited time and it's
totally in your hands so if you can kind
of use visuals like this you can you can
it just can be super empowering and
exciting to go and grab those green
branches that asymmetry of believing
that we had degrees of freedom in the
past but we've got lock in for the
future is so funny uh hang on a second
it literally couldn't no I I chose I'm
right here right now therefore I didn't
choose anything different in the past
and worrying about it can't change it
and I have the opportunity to do as much
as I want in the future all of these
different options are open to me there's
such a uh like a head bang against the
wall realization when you totally when
you notice that you've been doing that
obviously another another big piece of
of change that's happened recently has
been elon's takeover of Twitter I know
that you've spent a good bit of time
studying him have you noticed anything
interesting around the dynamic of the
response to what elon's been doing have
you have you observed anything that you
thought was pretty novel or interesting
yeah I mean I think um it's very early
look the way Elon tends to do stuff
and people forget sometimes this if you
know if you that you know in SpaceX and
Tesla started it was let's move let's
try stuff let's build build prototypes
let's make mistakes right
and when you look in retrospect at a
successful project and you see it
started that way it seems awesome wow
and they were just bold and they were
making mistakes and now look at led to
the success right we see it as just a
purely good thing
but when it's happening in that moment
before the success happens when it's in
that doubt that it might not you know
when when the success may or may not
happen
all of that raw experimentation and
failure and bumbling failure early on
looks
not good doesn't look chaotic out of
control yeah it it you know but if you
take a big zoom out and you realize like
this is how
Innovation often looks in the moment
um look at that take that your favorite
songs in the world and go on a time
machine back to when those songs are
being written and look at the original
verses and the original lyrics and the
original chords and and the playing
around on the piano that this composer
did and it's going to be a mess right
and it got to this beautiful place
eventually and so anyway what I see is
um we are in month one still basically
month two
um of elon's Twitter and so uh I see
um I see a bunch of early attempts some
you know uh some things that I think are
uh
um
uh promising and some things that I
think are you know pretty obvious
mistakes
um and
um so taking the Long View I'm like
great good go try [ __ ] make mistakes
be you know you know Innovative be
ruthless
um about your standards for this thing
and like see so I I'm happy but what I
see is a ton of people spiking the
football and being like aha see like oh
so and so you know you were you know you
were pro-free speech and now you're
doing this or you're you know you were
you know you're saying wanted to be
neutral I'm like yeah you know like it's
messy and someone I mean I think that
mostly it's if you don't like him and
you're rooting against the project then
this is a great time you know it's fun a
fun shot in front
things and act you know and seems like
it's about you know validating your
predictions
um no not not no not that everything I
think no not not that there are things
that could have been done differently or
better for sure um but I don't know for
me I would bet on I would bet on
long-term Twitter I bet in three years
my guess and again it could be wrong and
elon's the first to admit this he always
says that his projects all have a high
percentage of failure you know and
um so but I would my guess would be that
in three years Twitter is doing leading
the way in a lot of ways and that a lot
of other social media companies are
copying just like a bunch of Rocket
companies are now trying to learn how to
land Rockets copying SpaceX to try to
you know look at all the electric car
companies now or all the all the big car
companies who are cop who copied Tesla
essentially and started making electric
cars after they did so that's my guess
but you know no one's gonna have a
perfect track record maybe this is an
area this is going to be one of elon's
big failures maybe he'll try it it'll
turn into a disaster maybe social media
is unsalvageable
um and so I I I wouldn't say I wouldn't
put all my money down on it you know but
I but I would say if I had to bet on you
know
that Twitter being a big success story
I would give it more than a 50 shot of
that it seems like there might be an
element here that most of the stuff that
happens in engineering companies it
seems like Elon is taking a more sort of
engineering approach even when it comes
to the staff base I think he sent out an
email recently that basically warned
everybody that was working there there
are going to be some changes you are
going to have to work a lot harder than
you're used to if you don't like this
then feel free to leave
um most of this stuff it seems like
would be done in relative privacy you
know the stories coming out of Tesla you
know it's like a leaked Memo from sever
half a decade ago or whatever that we
see that we see now that's the sort of
stuff that we see whereas pretty much
everything that's happening at Twitter
is practicing in public
everything seems to be it's basically a
total Glassdoor policy Not By Design
necessarily although I'm sure that Elon
is thinking to himself anything that I
decide to put out on The Local Company
intranet needs to be visible to the
press and it needs to be acceptable by
the Press because it's not going to stay
private but there is definitely like a
more voyeuristic sense of the internal
um iterations of what's going on within
that company then there certainly were I
didn't know what what spacex's first 20
versions of the rocket looked like but I
know what Twitter blue and all of the
debates about what's going on online and
everybody somehow feels like they're
invested and they've got a say in how
Elon should be running this company but
no one thought that when it came to
Falcon 9 rocket design
of course I also saw a interview with
Joe Lonsdale the other day and he made a
a funny point which he was like you know
when Elon was first started getting into
rockets and cars they said what the
internet guy can't make rockets and cars
these don't happen in Silicon Valley
now people are saying the rocket and
cars guy can't
do internet I mean and it's just kind of
like
it's it's that
um
this is assuming that
um
you know success has to be you know
specialized but I think if you look at
what are the roots of what makes someone
successful in any industry they're often
the same it's you know
um being able to recruit the right
people
um having a clear goal being able to
reason from first principles and
innovate and it is sometimes in the
direct conflict of conventional wisdom
um being ruthless and you know
persistent over many years
um and so I mean it's just I just I
think none of this is you know uh let's
say rocket science but SpaceX is but
none of this is um is is is is you know
specialized to one industry or another
if you apply those principles in any
industry again you're not the CEO isn't
going to be doing it you're going to
hire expertise so you're going to get
the different expertise you need that
you don't have but like those the same
principles apply um and like as far as
you know
um him saying you have to be hardcore
and like work extra hours
I think it's totally valid to say this
is that's toxic that's bad that's not a
good way to have a company that's not a
good way to treat employees that's
that's a totally valid view but it's
also a free market and so I think you
know
um I think that
um
uh it's what's cool about it is he can
do that and he'll attract the kind of
people that are Workaholics and that
just are they would love to go to a
place where everyone is Hardcore right
think about like are those same people
criticizing people who want to play in
the NFL you think the NFL has chill work
hours it's the most hardcore around the
year round-the-clock demanding punishing
activity right are those people saying
you know uh the NFL is toxic for having
all this off-season practice
um you know no uh you know how about a
tireless activist who wants to go work
on a presidential campaign is working
Round the Clock
are they criticizing those people and
saying you know criticizing the campaign
for wow you're you want your people to
work on weekends no it's just these are
there's certain things that are hardcore
in life and military right I mean
there's certain things and elon's
basically saying this is my companies
are like the military in the NFL and the
political campaign that's just what
we're like and um it's not for everyone
and we it's going to filter out the
people who don't want that they can go
get a different job and the people who
do like it so I just I again you can say
this is bad that's totally valid just
like you can say it's unhealthy to join
the military or you're playing the NFL
and you shouldn't do totally valid
opinion but to say that he's doing
something like
um that something is like like you know
wrong with this like it shouldn't be
allowed to have something it's just like
or uh it's like you don't have to work
there it's like you know let him attract
I'm glad that hardcore people have
companies like this to go work at
because they'd be bored and under
stimulated in a normal company so anyway
I think it's great I think it's like
bring some of that into Silicon Valley
because Silicon Valley is known for
being very cushy and and which is great
they've raised the standards they have a
philosophy that that employees should be
treated really well and have great
work-life balance and I think that's
awesome right but bring some bring some
variety into Silicon Valley and say you
know there's also some really hardcore
companies here and you can go do that if
you want um and uh let people choose
there is a contingent of people out
there who want a hardcore life like yeah
exactly it seems to me that the the
people that are less passionate about
the stuff that they do struggle to put
themselves into the mindset of someone
that's obsessive like if someone is
absolutely applying your values to
everyone and saying everyone should have
your particular values you know like
um you know no one would it's like
someone else could say it's it's very
popular in our society it used to be
popular I think in in older America to
be like work hard you know work as hard
as you can you know that was that was
you know a high value now that's looked
down upon at least within like you know
the kind of Silicon Valley type crowds
that's right it's not
or on Twitter that's that that's bad
that's toxic right um but if someone
said you know what I'm gonna I Only
Wanna work four days a week and I wanna
retire early if I can because I want to
spend a ton of time with my family I
want to I just want to dig into my
family no one's like wow you're being
too hardcore that's toxic it's like let
people choose how they want to spend
their one life and for some people
nothing gets them going more than
working hard with a team to build
something they think is important and
that's their fun and that's what they
really enjoy and maybe it's their stage
in their life maybe they're 25 and maybe
when they're 40 they're not going to
want to do that anymore but they're 25
and they do and so again I just like
variety I like the idea I like I like
having people get to choose what fits
them the best how are you getting on
with writing your book
um well uh the book has been the the
book has been done for a while but fact
checking is a [ __ ] uh it's it's amazing
because you know I do this and I think
I'm being so rigorous you know I'm I'm
I'm I'm researching everything really
carefully and I'm checking what I'm
doing and I'm I'm making sure and then
you get a hardcore fact Checker and I
got two of them to go through and read
your book and it's amazing what they can
find problems with I mean and basically
they're you're paying them
to act like the most pedantic annoying
reader that will ever read the book
someone who is trying to point out all
the ways this book is wrong you
shouldn't trust this author because this
is wrong it's I'm basically saying be
that person and tell me everything that
they could possibly say and that sounds
great when you're hiring them except
when you're actually going through my
God it's like ah because it's sometimes
it's just so you know like well this is
technically you know not what every one
of the you know you know postmarkists
said you know there was this school and
you're like okay [ __ ] you know I
shouldn't say and I shouldn't generalize
and you know or this isn't you know oh
actually you know it wasn't just
this law you know that did this because
actually it existed in common law in
England before that and um and this is a
you know and I'm like oh my God and what
you don't want to do is you know if you
just do everything they say you're gonna
end up with a boring overly detailed
books everywhere just put an endnote and
it'll cut someone to say you know this
is too nuanced
to it's going to be boring if I do it do
it justice so I'm just going to cut it
or I'm going to put it in an endnote or
I'm just going to change the wording and
say in part it was developed by you know
so I'm getting better at like
trying to do the right you know go
through these fact checks efficiently
but I'm just about done with that
process
um and and it's being copy edited by a
different person
um and so it's in those final stages
which is way easier than when it's being
done but you know it's to drag it drags
on and uh getting close to being
finished yet as someone that's thought
and written a good bit about
procrastination in the past is there
anything that you learned from having
such a single large project that you're
working on for a good amount of time
okay yeah I mean I learned that uh
that a procrastinator who can learn how
to you know
be productive usually is relying on a
lot of kind of like crutches you know
one can be deadlines imposed by someone
else right that's great or collaboration
when you're accountable to someone else
or
um uh external pressure of different
kind like when I was publishing blog
posts every week there was like this
excitement of you know hey I owe this to
readers because I told them to be out
next week but also like the excitement
the adrenaline that comes from this is
about to go live like in two days you
know it would actually be something that
would help ease procrastination because
it was like you know dopamine just from
working on the project
this long Book Project
um without any you know feedback as I'm
going from readers and without any you
know has been taking away a lot of those
crutches so it's been very difficult so
I've done
um I've learned throughout the pro I've
actually this this has been a boot camp
for me over the last few years of
getting better at doing I've built a
bunch of new devices to help me like I
will say where would I want to be a week
from today like where do I want it where
it
what could I do in the next seven days
where a week from today I'd be very
happy with where I am in my progress
okay that's my goal
now I'm going to tell two friends
this is my goal and either I have to do
this and do a certain thing every day
certain problem or just something by the
end of the week and either way I owe you
and I have to venmo you
uh each you know a good amount of money
each day I fail
something where it's small enough that
you will do it it won't like be so
ridiculous that you just say I can't
sorry you have to actually be able to do
it but it hurts you know it's it's like
oh God like
can't believe I just lost that money so
I'm trying to you know even finding the
sweet spot with the amount of money and
with like the rules and and the you know
um and that works great if you can have
an internal ethic where you say I does
you know they won't know I can lie about
what I didn't I will not lie about this
I will be honest I will send it if I
didn't truly do it so that if you can't
pull off that internal ethic and you
find yourself lying okay that doesn't
work you have to come up with something
there so it's just what what are the
tools you can use to help push you
forward when the normal external
pressures are not and I've been working
on a bunch of those have some of your
friends ended up profiting massively for
your attempt at writing about yes I've
paid over a thousand dollars
in different overall uh uh and and but I
also got back some good solid cash from
them because they're also creators and
they've been also oh it's like a cartel
a pooled thing like a Deadpool but it's
for instead of who's dying it's who's
gonna hit the word count yes and it's so
fun when they fail and I Get Money
do you ever find yourself trying to
distract them or trying to sabotage them
oh yeah no I'm I'm rooting against them
fully um and um yeah so I mean that that
can be very helpful okay here's another
one I've been doing which is that I just
um
uh if I'm left to my own devices
I will dick around for a big huge Chunk
in the morning the morning's when I'm
energetic I'm feeling social is when I
want to text my friends or call or play
with my dogs or just I just feeling like
you know I don't work is such a bummer
I'm like I have all this fun energy but
it's also the best time to work the the
obvious like happy life and productive
life is you get up you're serious you
get your work done and you're free
you're off that's the school mentality
you know the bell rings at three you're
off for the day yes Save By the Bell
right
and to me at least I mean I'm sure some
people like to have their mornings free
and then they they hammer down in the
afternoon not for me it's not good
because I because I and I don't end up
enjoying my mornings I'm the dark
playground I've worked looming over me
I'm self-loathing that I haven't done
anything so how do I get myself to
actually you know
not dick around till two and then work
till dinner but actually try to work
till two and then take the time off
um
uh which kind of guarantees a productive
day you know because if you if you if
you mess around in the morning you can
end up actually just doing nothing that
day and that's really miserable
um and so and also you know not drifting
back with sleep how do I guarantee that
I'm like consistently working up early
working early for me is waking up at
eight you know I'm not no that's not for
most people um up early and working so
for me it was um I have um
um my colleague Alicia who's the
Waypoint manager of lots of things and
she and I've been working together for
seven years she knows exactly all my
faults and flaws like that probably
better than anyone she could write a
book on them and
um and one of the but she's always you
know willing to help in any way she can
and so I was like you know what would
help is it's I'm not gonna sit at the
computer and start [ __ ] around the
Internet or texting if someone's looking
at my screen that's embarrassing a you
can see what I'm doing it's weird but B
it's also just like it's so shameful to
procrastinate in front of someone it's
so like mortifying to like for someone
to watch you and I realized that like
it's I don't need that big a push to do
what I'm supposed to do it's not like
I'm you need to drag me Kicking and
Screaming I need it's like you know the
old feeling of oh damn class is starting
damn I I had my free Block
and it's not that I'm like screaming
it's just like okay you know it's Monday
morning and you just gotta do it and you
don't want to but you have to and so
suddenly having someone looking at my
screen is that it's like uh I don't want
to work but are you saying that you've
had you've had your manager Alicia just
sit and watch over your shoulder like a
supervisory parrot in person but also
she hurt her knee
um and was and was immobile for a while
and we were you know zooming and we
realized that that works really well too
I just go on to uh slack video I share
my screen my whole screen
and she's working it's not like she's
sitting there staring but at any given
point she might be looking at the screen
I don't know when that is oh you've got
to pan up the virtual panopticon going
on yeah
dude that's a cool solution and also it
doubles up as the purpose of you know
she's a collaborator and all this stuff
she's very involved in the writing and
the the uh the editing she was kind of
my main editor and so I'll often say to
her you know like do you like this new
sentence or like do you think we need a
source here you know maybe you know can
you can you like look into this you know
make sure that got that right so it's
it's also just nice to be able to have
someone there you can kind of like
bounce something off as you go
so but you know then sometimes I'm like
oh as I'm writing I think oh that's an
interesting thought that would be a
perfect tweet what I just wrote would be
a perfect tweet also and my instinct is
to go tweet I'm like no I'm not gonna go
tweet when someone's looking at my
screen that's really embarrassing like
procrastinating thing to do right now so
I just won't go do it but if I if you
weren't there
I would go to tweet right and you think
okay that's five minutes big deal
but it's not I get stuck on Twitter now
now I'm scrolling for an hour later so
it's it's having someone that prevents
that little you know quote five minute
break that was actually an hour actually
saves me an hour and every day now at
noon I'm like wow I've gotten three
hours of work done real focused work
done and so anyway these are examples of
hacks that work for me I think every
procrastinator does it for different
reasons different weird psychological
emotional reasons
um and everyone needs to come up with
solutions that can
um help them and there's no
one-size-fits-all solution for this I'm
about to Embark it looks like on writing
a book and that means that I'm I've got
particular voyeuristic interest in in
the tools that you've used so yeah I
mean all of those sound like the
woodwork
um I had I had an idea that I came up
with about a year ago called anxiety
cost and I think that's what you're
referring to on the morning evening
thing so opportunity cost by doing a
thing you can't do another thing you
have the choice between the gym and the
theme park by going to the theme park
you can't go to the gym anxiety cost is
the pain that you suffer mentally by
thinking about as yet undone tasks that
could be gotten rid of by just doing the
tasks so each day your to-do list begins
and you when you wake up in the morning
you have to meditate and walk the dog
and answer emails the longer that you
take to walk the dog meditate and answer
emails the more time you spend during
that day thinking about the fact you
haven't done those things whereas if you
just do them if you front load them
towards the start of the day you're just
bathing in this sort of Glorious same
exact task can cause a variable amount
of pain is what you're saying you know
correct if you do it later it causes you
wait and it's almost like a physical
wound
um and it's like there's something
that's hurting you consistently and then
you do it
it's like um it's almost like you know I
don't know you're like yeah it's like
and you can patch up the wound once you
do it and it's like you can do the task
and it takes a little bit of pain to do
it but there's no long sitting there in
pain with the wound or you can you know
so yeah I think that's a very clever way
to kind of
think about it is um
the the you know actually think of that
as a quantity as a metric yeah
postponing postponing a task extends the
pain right right exactly look you have
to do the same pain either way at some
point to do it which is pain you know
it's not like you should pretend that
work is fun it's often not
um
but you that pain is is a constant it's
going to happen either way it's a
certain amount and it can like drag on
like leaving this long wake of pain and
it's you know or it can uh it can just
be done without that wig yeah
you had a uh article where you were
talking about the person that you're
supposed to marry and you said whatever
you do don't marry the wrong person
given that young people at the moment
are having less sex than ever and both
children and marriage are being delayed
more than ever plus there's more
optionality than ever it kind of seems
like an increasingly difficult decision
to commit to a partner do you think this
is a like a paradox of choice Barry
Schwartz thing going on like what what
do you think of some of the issues
that's happening here foreign
so this is not something this particular
problem I've I've seen like the graphs
and the stats on it and um and I've
heard theories I don't have much
original thought here I've heard
theories about
like
men are getting old like there's more
sexless men than there used to be and
the theories I've heard is not that
they're and it's not happening for women
as much right and so why
and the theories are that it's the apps
create this marketplace where you know
in the old days
um a woman
would
um you know two people would start
dating who met in the office right just
say or they met in the local bar uh or
they met through a friend right and so
this is kind of like your local world
would provide you with mates and people
within that world would match up just
naturally
but now it's like a
um
that same woman
can go on to an app and select the most
desirable guy that she can find and
maybe that person is more desirable to
her than anyone in her little local
world
and she can and and and it's not like oh
well okay but that guy's now taken
because a lot of times there's casual
sex right so you have that guy
can have you know casual sex with 40
people in a year if he wants to right so
all these women are you know sleeping
with the smaller pool of super desirable
guys and it's leaving a bunch of the
guys
um in the local networks and the local
groups
um with no one so this is the theory
I've heard which makes a ton of sense it
almost reminds me a little of like
um you know in the old days if you were
you know good guitar player you could
play for your you know friends and you'd
be the one you'd say I'm gonna put on a
little concert tonight and you know in
your village the 50 people would come
listen and you had this gratification
where you could provide this great gift
you could give to people your art and
other people would come listen and that
was it and you had this you you know you
had your dreams I'm playing guitar for
people everywhere now with the world of
that we're in now I mean uh you know 100
150 years later you've got everyone can
go and listen to the best guitarist in
the world on Spotify so you know you're
not gonna go and you know you're all
going to go to Madison Square Garden to
that concert and not going to go to your
local thing as often and so there's all
these artists out there that have this
gift to give that no one's taking
because they're they're pretty good
um and no no one needs wow there's no
need for pretty good art anymore because
you have
everywhere you look it's so easy to
great so you have the small number of
artists having huge numbers of fans and
you have most artists having no fans and
that's in some ways cool because for
Consumer it's great right everyone has a
world-class entertainment for the
artists for most artists it sucks and
and you could so that's to me it's the
same kind of concept that's happening
with dating you know and and again I I
don't know this from my own research I
know this from see hearing other people
say this Theory and
um but of course the out that the
the
um it's the consequence this is not good
right it's sad
um you know there's a lot of people that
are real mean to like in cells they're
like oh you know like these in the cell
man it's like well but that's sad
they're not they're like they're lonely
and they're not getting like a core
human need that in 50 years ago they the
same people would have gotten and that
leads to I think that's one of the
things that makes people you know breeds
anger and regret you know you know I
think
sexually frustrated countries are going
to have more war probably you know not
not you know I don't go overboard here
but like so um I'm always rooting for
like when I see a stat like that there's
no like shot and fight or anything I'm
always just like rooting for as many
people to be like satisfied in their
lives and sexually happy as possible
because it's just gonna you know even
just selfishly it's gonna create a
better Society
um if the more people there are so I
don't know what the answer is there
um but in my general advice to someone
if they
are having you know if they want to find
a a relationship and by the way not
everyone does I think we should move
towards a world where some people want
to stay single their whole lives or some
people want to date and not be married
and it should be much more fluid than it
is right now where it's like this binary
thing like why are you not yet married
you're supposed to be married from this
age on you know it's like that's a
little bit unnuanced but
um but I always say that you know it's
like if you wanted to
um
uh
uh if you wanted to
find
um
so basically if you want to get you know
discover anything you want to go try a
bunch of things you know we talked about
what Elon does he tries a ton of things
sees what fails sees what it succeeds
right you know versus imagine if you're
trying to create a strategy for a
company and you sit there in the war
room all day just talking and talking
and discussing and trying to come up
with the perfect absolute perfect
strategy before you execute and then you
execute it that's not going to be as
successful as the company that says
let's come up with something let's try
it let's come with something let's try
it let's learn let's learn let's get our
hands dirty so dating is the same I feel
like it's get out there and you rather
than people sitting there and thinking
about you know torturing themselves in
their head what do I want what do I need
in a partner
go out there and go on 50 dates in the
next year and you know maybe one of your
points originally was that it's hard to
find dates and I don't know if that's
true but I just think I always say you
know like just go on lots of dates if
you can
you also had a tweet that I really
enjoyed asking looking at an important
life skill is recognizing the difference
between criticism from people who don't
care about you and don't root for you
and criticism from those who do the
first is best ignored and the second
warrants attention and reflection one of
the issues that you have online is that
it's very difficult to work out
somebody's intentions and whether or not
they do have your best interests at
heart how do you deal with criticism in
this way
so yeah online I mean a few it's people
say it's hard but I can usually tell
online I think I have a pretty
first of all most of the tweets that are
like nasty towards me right and there's
not too many I mean I feel like I'm
lucky that I don't have too many like
haters but if I tweet something
political for example or anything
controversial you're gonna have hate
hate it hate
um hater tweets
the really nasty things I look and
almost never they almost never follow me
so I'm like these they don't know who I
am I am some dehumanized [ __ ] guy
over there they don't have no idea who I
am they're just and so they they see
someone they think they hate they don't
even know my you don't even know what I
think
about you know but they see one tweet
they put me in a box they demonize me
and I mean I don't first want to take
that personally I'm like this person
doesn't know me at all it's like they're
a good thing to remember is that someone
who's being real nasty to you online
probably was if you went and looked at
their their other tweets they probably
have been nasty to 12 other people that
day in the same exact way they're going
around in this mood doing this you're
caught in a long line of fire so I don't
give a [ __ ] about nastickiness from
someone who is not my follower
because they don't know who I am now
when someone follows me okay I'm going
to pay a little more attention if
they're being nasty though you know
really personal I'm like this is not my
kind of person this is not my kind of
person uh I don't know I don't make
friends with this kind of person who
makes a really kind of mean ad hominem
attack really kind of like you know
cynical sassy you know tone I'm like
this isn't my kind of so I'm not going
to worry too much about this kind of
person right like
um and so I also usually don't pay too
much attention to it
um
then there's a comment from someone who
does follow me and I can usually tell
that this is someone who likes me and
likes my stuff and they're disappointed
in this particular tweet or they
they usually resonate with me but they
don't hear right
and that's super interesting to me now
it's pay attention sometimes that hurts
those are the ones that might hurt
because it's it's the person you know
who you know you're thinking
anything I do is going to create Rando
haters and is gonna get nastiness from
the really cynical kind of ad hominem
type people out there that's just
inevitable but but if if I'm actually
kind of like you know turning off people
who normally like my stuff that's
interesting it doesn't necessarily mean
I'm wrong sometimes I want to challenge
people who like my stuff too and
sometimes I just there's just a
disagreement but it doesn't necessarily
mean I'm wrong but it definitely warns
paying attention to and and the nice
thing about having a good size following
is that it's not just one person it's
that I have a sample size so if I get
you know 400 comments very quickly it's
like I can start to see there seems to
be a decent frequency here of people who
actually seem like genuine part of like
the way but why Community who really did
didn't like what I said or things I
think I'm gonna think I'm off on this
and that is uh that means a ton to me
and and I'll reflect on it
um
and I feel grateful that I get that you
know a lot of you know you have to have
a sizable following of people who do
care about you and like your stuff to
get that quality feedback from people
who care about you so anyway these are
some like little things I I just kind of
feel like I've developed a slight sixth
sense for this over time
um
and then of course in real life it's
much easier you know but it's hard to
get
constructive feedback from people who
care about you in real life because most
people who care about you don't want to
hurt you they don't want to hurt your
feelings right they want to be nice to
you they want to compliment you it's
almost like uh real life is the opposite
of the internet on the internet it seems
like people tune up their displeasure
and decide to just throw shade or try
and dunk on someone for no reason and in
the real world it's difficult to get
criticism out of most of the people that
are around you because they're concerned
about hurting your feelings or they want
to come across well or they care about
well in general the Paradox is that the
more online or in the real world the
more someone knows and cares about you
the less likely they are to give you
criticism and that's exactly the
criticism that you do want and the
criticism that you're more likely to get
is from people who are rooting against
you who they don't you know often don't
know you are Anonymous and that's the
criticism that's not as valuable because
because if you think about what it's
motivated the reason I say it it you
should listen to the kind from people
who care about you is not like that you
know you can learn from any criticism
but the people who are if you if
especially in real life
if there's someone who you just think
you know you know deep down who some of
the friends you think just you know
whether it's a stage in their life they
are just who they are or the kind of
relationship you have with them they're
not rooting for you they're happy when
you fail they're happy when you don't
succeed you know it's a colleague at
work or whatever and the criticism from
that person is just you think about
where it's coming from their goal deep
down
their their hope is that you do badly
that things work out worse for you right
so they're giving me this criticism
maybe they're doing it to boost how you
feel about them so they're going to give
you good criticism so that you think
they're a good person but maybe they're
literally doing something that they that
they think is going to somehow hurt you
like why would you take help from
someone why would you you know who is
whose goal is to push you off the cliff
you know you're on the cliff and someone
wants to push you further down it why
would you take their hand it doesn't
make any sense so someone who does care
about you and gives you criticism
especially given that it's not fun to
give criticism to people you care about
right so they're going out of their way
they're doing something that's hard for
them that's not pleasant for them
and you believe that their hope is that
you do better right that is precious if
you can get it uh so and look it's some
of the nicest people I know
they're great at a lot of things they're
not going to be good at giving criticism
because they're too nice and that those
are some of the best people I know right
and that's like one of their great
qualities is that they're nice but that
happens to mean they're not going to be
great for criticism there are certain of
your friends who are in that sweet spot
where they're good friends they care
about you they're rooting for you and
they also are not shy they're open maybe
they do it as a you know in a humor
humorous way or maybe they're just
confrontational and you really gotta
treasure those those what those people
can do because uh and seek it out from
them I mean you know it's it's really
really valuable
that's a really interesting point to
think about how you curate your group of
friends to not just be yes people that
tell you what you want to hear because
it's actually rarer to find a friend who
is both in the caring but critically
able Camp than it is to find someone
who's caring and just comforting and
tells you what you want to hear
sometimes it's the people who care most
about you I mean in some ways if you're
you know if you're dating someone that's
not good for you and everyone knows it
right
the nice friend who says yeah you know I
love them good it's going great oh it's
going good good you know
it's not that's not their Shining Moment
as your friend right there you know
they're not actually you know they're
they're in their head thinking oh this
is bad but like I want them to feel good
in this moment that's a little bit
almost like of a selfish Act
um versus the person who will kind of
say
you sure it's good like I don't know I'm
a little worried about you know or or
you know if you're doing um
a
you know if if um if if you're if you're
annoying everyone at a party or
somewhere you're you're you're too drunk
or something a friend who was like
kindly tell you know you know the next
day maybe you don't wanna you know that
person's doing something unpleasant to
help you versus everyone else who's kind
of thinking is not my problem nice
because the the critic is paying a price
personally in order to be able to advise
you to become better so yeah they care
about you so much that they'll go and
actually tell you versus if it's you
know if uh if you cared less wow you
wouldn't go through that you'd think you
know it's I'll you know so
um yeah I mean I think
um especially you know we're really
fragile about you know artists and
creators and entrepreneurs and these
people who create stuff they can be very
fragile their egos their self-esteem
their self-worth
and so when you know when you're making
something new and you're you know trying
to be bold
um you really want to specifically seek
out because there's again there's the
person who's always going to say that's
great I love your song
even if they hate it right and that
person's you know again they're nice but
they're actually not helping you very
much and they can lead you to then kind
of you know you can be going down a bad
path and they'll just let you go
um and then there's the person who's
rooting against you you got to be very
careful because that person will try to
hurt you even if it's subconscious
they'll try to hurt your confidence you
know and if it's good they'll whatever
and then but it's like you know to find
that person who will just be honest with
you
um about how you're
you know
you know what you're working on it's
just it's yeah it's it's hard to find
friendships are a Minefield man look Tim
let's bring this one home uh wait but
why on absolutely everything have you
got any idea when you're
worst harshest critic fact Checker
people are going to be finished have you
got anything close to a release date
yeah it should be early February oh dude
how excited are you for that
very then I have to turn around
immediately and work on another book so
my friend Douglas Murray says that once
the book is published that's when the
real work begins so you're going to be
doing a double job for a little while
yeah that's okay I'll just be happy to
have one under my belt all right man
dude I appreciate you thank you yeah
thanks for having me on what's Happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
peace
[Music]